bonjour pierre connaît sa merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous dans la
matinale de rtl france
les femmes saoudiennes autorisés à vivre
seul sans l'autorisation d'un tuteur est
ce que c'est une réelle avancée selon
nous avec un peu d'avancé oui mais vous
n'êtes point de départ est déjà
tellement bas que n'importe quelle
annonce saoudienne les prix
effectivement comme un immense progrès
de démocratie vous rendez compte de
l'état dans lequel on est mené les
critères de jugement sur ce pays c'est à
dire qu'on considère qu'une femme puisse
exister en tant qu'individu en tant que
citoyenne est considérée comme une
avancée démocratique dans un pays où
jusque là elle n'avait aucun droit donc
très bien pour mieux encore une fois si
les choses s'étaient passées dans je ne
sais quel pays africains on aurait dit
quand même c'est incroyable c'est
inadmissible et c'est par là on est on a
tellement abc dont critères de jugement
sur l'arabie saoudite que finalement
tout annoncé pris comme un scoop
une révolution chercher parce que
jusqu'à présent elle n'avait pas droit
de le faire sans l'avis d'un tuteur que
ce soit un frère un père ou un membre de
la famille wef - fils a perdu la vie
vers des mers qui était sous
l'autorisation de leur fils alors
pourquoi aujourd'hui cette cette
nouvelle avancée si je puis dire ben
d'abord limitant l'avancé c'est à dire
n'oubliez pas qui a encore une dizaine
de femmes qui sont emprisonnés en arabie
saoudite pour chiots en vertu d'une loi
antiterroriste
c'est à dire est pas parce qu elles ont
fait des actes héroïques c'est parce que
leur posture sont considérés comme des
contestations de la loi
constitutionnelle et donc elles sont
jugées sur la base d'une loi
antiterroriste mans
d'autre part un effectivement c'est
pourquoi cette question vous est
parfaitement raison c'est un effet
indirect de la ferc a choisi c'est à
dire que le l'arabie saoudite c'est
tellement trouver dans au coeur du
cyclone après cette horrible assassinat
de journaliste du times que moi mais ben
salman est obligée d'annoncer un certain
nombre de réformes
évidemment font grincer des dents en
arabie saoudite 1 il faut pas s'imaginer
que c'est un consensus international
vous avez quand même un régime qui est
appuyée sur deux piliers qui sont
évidemment la dynastie des saoud mais
aussi toutes les hiérarchies religieuses
et dans cette hiérarchie religieuse est
aussi immobile qu'un pachyderme coincé
dans un marécage quoi donc vous aurez de
toute façon des questions internes
d'autres à l'intérieur de la famille al
saoud n'oubliez pas qu'on a toujours un
un 'très normalement héritiers qui a été
remplacé par mohamed ben salman était
disparu c'est parce qu'il est venu donc
on est sur le cinquième ou sixième très
seul ou comment dire de la famille
royale qui vont aujourd'hui on n'a plus
de nouvelles d'envoyer comme finalement
ces critères et puis évidemment pour
tous à vous avez toujours cette
affaire'' lé clou j'ai rien à la soul
cette jeune fille qui s'était autorisé à
conduire avant que mohamed bin salman ne
leur concède ce droit et qui est
toujours en prison donc on est face à un
système si vous voulez où il faut pas
que les critères de jugement sarah sa
baisse l'arabie saoudite reste à le
payer extrêmement archaïque dans lequel
ce genre de petites mesurettes si vous
voulez permet de compenser
l'extraordinaire déficit de légitimité
que la chair cachottière introduit sur
ce pays le droit des femmes c'est en
quelque sorte la vitrine là la caution
vertueuse du prince mohammed bin salman
oui absolument absolument vis-à-vis des
etats-unis si vous voulez vous trouver
dans une situation vous avez de vous
donner quelques concessions pour ne pas
avoir à céder sur autre chose
encore une fois c'est le land d'analysé
qui prêche qui pêchent si vous voulez je
vous dis quand il à faire cachottier
tout le monde s'élance et là dessus mais
c'était le cinquième quart personnalités
politiques présents à des familles
princières qui disparaissait alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas parlé des
quatre autres parce que pour les médias
que voulez-vous que ça signifie qu'un
prince héritier saoudien un prince
saoudien disparaissent on dit ces gens
là sont tellement différents nous qu'on
en est même plus si vous voulez examiner
la logique de répression et puis sur la
jeune homme à la cool c'est parce
qu'elle a eue ce réseau de soutien
extérieur si vous voulez que cette
affaire est en train de ce réseau se
résoud sous la pression internationale
donc c'est une mesurette il faut le
saluer c'est très bien il reste
maintenant à savoir qu'est-ce qui va
s'appliquer parce qu'encore une fois
quand on reste dans les provinces aux
formes de l'arabie saoudite est ce que
les femmes bon à voir où on pouvoir fait
jouir de ce droit ça j'en doute
ça c'était ma dernière question
justement la répression qui demeure vous
en avait parlé
quid quid des femmes ça ça reste un
signalement des lois qui sont
applicables à une partie de saoudiennes
plutôt privilégié je dirais il ya le
poids des traditions qui est très lourd
en arabie saoudite tradition oui mais si
vous voulez à chaque fois le tribunal
fera un tribunal religieux qui jugera de
ce tout ça donc
comment voulez vous qu'un juge encore
une fois formés dans la version la peur
archaïque de la charia et qui se trouve
légitimé par le par le système que vous
voulez va accepter ou à trouver des
billets jurisprudentielle pour ne pas
appliquer cette réforme
donc voilà le l'état est l'année de la
critique je comprends que je sois assez
sévère mais évidemment ils les
déceptions et heppell s'il voulait sur
l'arabie saoudite
il faut quand même bien que c'est
réaliste et encore une fois j'ai fait un
bouquin sur le lobby saoudien en france
je doute que ce lobby est vis-à-vis de
l'arabie saoudite une distance critique
vrai véritablement significative pour
que ce pays se réforme
voilà donc c'est un peu ça mon c'est
pour ça que je suis plutôt donc plutôt
distant si vous voulez vis-à-vis de
l'appréciation de la réalité de cette
mesure pour que les tribunaux de la
charia valide une telle mesure y at il
des concessions faites de la part du
régime des saoud ben c'est une bonne
question parce que si vous voulez encore
une fois on est amené à examiner ce qui
pour nous en tant qu'occidentaux a une
valeur on va pas aller examiner ce qui
peut avoir sur le plan de la charia et
des pouvoirs comment dire des religieux
de signification dans le conte
signification en termes de politique
intérieure saoudienne donc je suis pas
sûr qu effectivement il n'est pas des
concessions bon cela dit moi mes
domaines salman semble avoir un pouvoir
qu'il a c'est comment dire assez solide
mais encore une fois il est assez solide
à condition qu'il ne soit pas sous la
double pression de ces religieux et
d'appuyer delà de la communauté
internationale fasse pression une
confiance sur le la communauté
internationale pour faire pression sur
mohammed salman quand on a eu les froids
yab l'assassinât tâche hobby et corsé
mais aucune sanction alors que pour la
faire skripal en russie on a pris des
sanctions contre tout le monde je me dis
mon chat va ton avenir radieux beaucoup
pierre connais ça d'avoir répondu ce
matin en direct à nos questions sur arte
france